roh vision que l'on à chaque matin chez
bruno guillon stop c'est demain demain
l'eurovision on va serrer fort les
points pour que la france cette année
peut-être gagne après la deuxième place
de barbara praveen l'année dernière dès
nos premiers pas à l'école en fait on a
grandi dans les écoles du monde pour les
écoles associatives en immersion en
langue bretonne on est très fier de
pouvoir porter cette langue cet héritage
aussi et puis de montrer à tout le monde
à toute l'europe que que la france est
un pays très riche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
john gomery quoi
le torse en fait le groupe albanais s
présenter un titre féministe mêlant
électro et chants bretons il fini
avant-dernier du classement
il a donné toute hâte à vue pour dire
sans regarder sans famille quand j'étais
enfant à la maison nature vécu ça en
musique ça apporte en eurovision tous
les styles tous les gnagna bla bla bla
bla bla sauf que pouf quasi s'est passé
mais c'est bien un an avant en u15
pardon il est ou sera t elle aider et ce
qu'ils pensaient de l'eurovision est
confronté par la france alors mêlant
aller est-ce que la plupart des chansons
qui sont à l'eurovision sont ils font
honte ces deux là revenez avec une bonne
chanson qui n'est pas maintenant mais je
sais pas si on a le droit à ma des
sédiments sur un téléphone ou acteurs et
tous ne pas retenir la secrète griezmann
et
je conduisais témoin à kiosque l'aube et
spain cusin brigade et son profil
variable du ring et non parce
qu'il ya bientôt leur
robe longue je pense a dû prendre du
temps
c'est noël puisque le lancement autre
voie pas son âge dès qu'elle danse aa je
réapparais
ça tient pas ses meilleurs moments là
moi j'ai kiffé ça m'a rappelé tu vois
les fêtes de noël quand tu as tant elle
est bourrée adanson adam et que tout le
monde est à table genre mais arrête
monique assieds toi
[Applaudissements]
avant guerre apprenez le la mode est
encore aux femmes gironde et ses
articles de presse féminine américaine
invite les jeunes femmes à prendre du
poids je vous jure jugez plutôt les
filles minces ne sont pas glamour
comment avoir des formes généreuses il y
en a un autre regardez ça si tu veux
être populaire tu ne peux pas être mince
et mon préféré arrive
les garçons ne me regarde pas si je suis
mince mais j'ai gagné 5 kg et depuis
tous les hommes sont à mes pieds
[Applaudissements]
en espagne
oui les fans
on se souviendra toute sa vie certaines
personnes au premier rang aussi parce
que je trouvais que c'était mal un jour
une grande partie de l'aide show de dos
[Musique]
je suis sorti avec monique
zac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la victoire en chansons l'ukraine
triomphe à l'eurovision
631 points un score exceptionnel grâce
au soutien du public
il est dans cette soirée pour avoir
allumé l'étincelle de la paix la
fraternité et mika petite confidence je
suis complètement fan de vaud merci du
fond du coeur je vous aime yoyo power
caillou un signe d'espoir c'est en tout
cas la manière dont ce succès a été
perçu à kiev part volodymyr zelensky
notre courage impressionnent le monde
notre musique conquiert l'europe nous
ferons de notre mieux pour accueillir un
jour les participants et les invités de
l'eurovision dans la ville ukrainienne
de marioupol libre pacifique
reconstruite
car la tradition veut que le pays qui
remporte l'eurovision l'organisent
l'année suivante